[Music]
one of the most central features of what
we could call the setting of philip k
dicks to android's dream of electric
sheep besides things like the war having
been fought radioactive dust being
everywhere and animals being rare is
this
quasi-religion
we could call it of mercerism partly
religion partly psychotherapy partly
philosophy partly experience and it's
centered around this guy mercer
and the practice of using what's called
an empathy box in order to attain a
state of fusion and this is something
that divides human beings and androids
they
not only
can't participate in the
fusion they also kind of can't wrap
their heads around what's going on in it
what human beings are getting out of it
and we first encounter the empathy box
and mercer in chapter two
and it's through the eyes and
remembrances and we could say inner
narration of john isadore the special
he lives in a building all by himself
and he's you know thinking i'm going to
go off to work and then you know he
comes back
and
he says time to grasp the handles he
said to himself and cross the living
room to the black empathy box when he
turned it on the usual faint smell of
negative ions surged from the power
supply he breathed in eagerly already
buoyed up he's anticipating a good
experience right then the cathode ray
tube glowed like an imitation feeble tv
image a collage formed made of
apparently random colors trails and
configurations which until the handles
were grasped amounted to nothing so
taking a deep breath to study himself he
grasped the twin handles this is the
sort of entrance into it you grab the
two and now you're transported
the visual image congealed he saw at
once a famous landscape the old brown
barren ascent with tufts of dried out
bone-like weeds poking slantedly into a
dim and sunless sky
one single human was one single figure
more or less human informed toiled its
way up the hillside an elderly man
wearing a dull featureless robe covering
as meager as if it had been snatched
from the hostile emptiness of the sky
the man
william mercer plotted ahead and as he
grasped the handles john isidor
gradually experienced a waning of the
living room in which he stood
and he found himself instead as always
before entering into the landscape of
drab hill drab sky and at the same time
he no longer witnessed the climb of the
elderly man his own feet now scraped
sought purchase among the familiar loose
stones he felt the same old painful
irregular roughness beneath his feet and
again smelled the acrid haze of the sky
not earth sky but that of some place
alien
distant and yet by means of the empathy
box instantly
available so
the empathy box
puts you into
at worst a virtual reality and perhaps
something more perhaps a
connection with mercer himself
it goes on he had crossed over in the
usual perplexing fashion physical
merging
accompanied
by mental and spiritual identification
with wilbur mercer had reoccurred so in
using the empathy box mercer and the
user are now sharing the same
consciousness this the same
memories or experiences at least for a
while
and it goes on further
he says as it did for everyone who at
this moment clutched the handles either
here on earth
or on one of the colony planets he
experienced them
the others incorporated the babble of
their thoughts heard in his own brain
the noise of their many individual
existences
so let me
talk about that for a moment that the
others now
are
part of this experience as well
so it's not just mercer and each
individual user it's the users in
relation to each other with mercer as
being you might say the catalyst that
allows all of these consciousnesses to
precipitate out and to exist in relation
to each other and so he says they and he
cared about one thing this fusion of
their mentalities oriented their
attention on the hill
the climb the need to ascend
and so that is what centers them
and
you know then they are going to reach
the top and then another key component
to this a rock hurled at him struck his
arm he felt the pain he half turned and
another rock sailed past him missing him
it collided with the earth and the sound
startled him who
he wondered appearing to see as
tormentors the old antagonists
manifesting themselves at the periphery
of his vision
it or they had followed him all the way
up to the hill and would remain at the
top
he remembered or he's anticipating the
top the sudden leveling of the hill when
the climb ceased and the other part
began which is going to be in many
respects much worse
and everybody else is feeling the same
thing
then within him the mutual babble of
everyone else and fusion broke the
illusion of aloneness you felt it too
he thought yes the voices answered we
got hit on the left arm it hurts like
hell and so
this is the opportunity to
share consciousness and experiences and
affectivity
and thoughts
with other people in this this fusion
so
this is a really central part of it and
you know who are these antagonists if we
skip ahead a little bit to chapter three
where rick deckard the bounty hunter is
now reflecting on things you know he
talks about you know empathy and what
it's for
but
um
here's the key part for mercerism
the empathetic gift blurred the
boundaries between hunter and victim
between successful and defeated as in
the fusion with mercer
everyone ascended together or when the
cycle had come to an end fell together
into the trough of the tomb world
and he goes on and he says as long as
some creature experienced joy the
condition for all their creatures
included a fragment of joy if any living
being suffered then for all the rest the
shadow could not be entirely
cast off right so this is an important
part of it and then rick thinks about
androids
and he says in retiring killing an andy
he did not violate the rule of life laid
down by mercer
you shall kill
only the killers now notice the
importance of that
it's not saying
you will not kill at all
right which would actually be feasible
for
many human beings within the society
that uh you know deck art and isidore
live in where animal life is incredibly
you know sacred and respected
um and human life is generally not taken
by other humans right
androids are left out of the equation as
we see in the work and androids are
conscious of being left out of the
equation as well you will kill only the
killers the antagonists in this fusion
process or
in the case of rick deckard killing
androids right mercer had told them the
year that empathy boxes first appeared
on earth and in mercerism as it evolved
into a full theology the concept of the
killers had grown insidiously in
mercerism an absolute evil plucked at
the threadbare cloak of the tottering
ascending old man
but it was never clear who or what this
evil presence was
a mercerite
sensed evil without understanding it put
another way a mercerite was free to
locate the nebulous presence of the
killers wherever he saw fit for rick
deckard an escaped humanoid robot which
had killed its master which had been
equipped with an intelligence greater
than that of many human beings which had
no regard for animals which possessed no
ability to feel empathetic joy for
another's life-form success or grief at
its defeat that for him
epitomized the killers so even though
deckard himself is not a you know very
keen follower of mercerism it does
provide him with a framework in which
killing the killers the androids helps
make sense out of his life now going
back to chapter
two with isidore remembering these
things and remembering it in fusion
we get to hear part of mercer's story
and this is mercer sort of revealing
things to him once it had been different
back before the curse had come an
earlier happier part of life
they his foster parents frank and cora
mercer had found him floating on an
inflated rubber air rescue raft off the
coast of new england or head up in
mexico he did not now remember the
circumstances childhood had been nice he
had loved all life especially the
animals
had in fact been able
for a while
for a time to bring back dead animals as
they had been so this is really key
about mercer he lived with rabbits and
bugs wherever it was either on earth or
a colony world he'd forgotten that too
but he recalled the killers because they
arrested him as a freak more special
than the other specials and due to that
everything had changed now again this is
what mercer is
giving all the people in fusion as they
remember what he remembers
local law prohibited the time reversal
faculty by which the dead returned to
life they'd spelled it out to him during
his 16th year he continued for another
year to do it secretly but an old woman
had told without his parents consent
they
the killers had bombarded the unique
nodule which had formed in his brain had
attacked it with radioactive cobalt and
this had plunged him
into a different world
one of whose existence he had never
suspected this is the tomb world
it had been a pit of corpses and dead
bones and he struggled for years to get
up from it the donkey and especially the
toad the creatures most important to him
had vanished had become extinct only
rotting fragments an eyeless head here
part of a hand there remained
at last a bird which had come there to
die told him where he was he had sunk
down into the tomb world he could not
get out until the bones strewn around
him grew back into living creatures he
had become joined to the metabolism of
other lives
and until they rose he could not either
how long that part of the cycle had
lasted he did not now know
nothing had happened generally so it had
been measureless without anything
happening you can't tell time passing
but at last the bones had regained flesh
the empty eye pits had filled up and the
new eyes had seen while meanwhile the
restored beaks and mouths had cackled
barked and catawalled
possibly he had done it perhaps the
extra sensory note of his brain had
finally grown back or maybe he hadn't
accomplished it maybe it was a natural
process anyhow he was no longer sinking
he'd begun to ascend along with the
others
long ago he'd lost sight of them he
found himself evidently climbing alone
but they were there they still
accompanied him he felt them strangely
inside him so mercer becomes something
like a
resurrected um you know what would we
call him
catalyst
messiah in some respects
a bringer of life protector of life
coming up from the tomb world coming up
from the realm
of death and decay and this is going to
be another
central idea as well that pops up
you know deckard himself
acknowledges that there's you know all
of this stuff going on and mercer is at
the center of isidore in explaining
um mercerism
uh also notes that
as he talks about kipple the only real
exception to this is is mercer but he
also explains mercerism
to an android and the androids don't
really like mercerism in fact they're
resentful of it right so when pris first
shows up
um he says
[Music]
here we go no one can win against kipple
um it's a universal principle the entire
universe is moving moving towards a
final state of total almost
capitalization
except of course
for the upward climb of wilbur mercer
which human beings can participate in
the girl item i don't see any relation
that's what mercerism is all about again
he found himself puzzled don't you
participate in fusion don't you own an
empathy box
after a pause the girl said carefully i
didn't bring mine with me i assume i'd
find one here
but an empathy box he said stammering is
an excitement is the most personal
possession you have it's an extension of
your body
it's the way you touch other humans it's
the way you stop
being alone but you you know that
everyone knows that mercer even lets
people like me he broke off but too late
he had already told her and he could see
by her face the flicker of sudden
aversion that she knew i almost passed
the iq test but i'm not very special
only moderately not like some you see
but that's what that's what mercer
doesn't care about and then bris has a
great one-liner as far as i'm concerned
you can count that as a major objection
to
mercerism so again we see the contrast
between the human
and the android here
now there's a very important set of
passages that we find taking place in
chapter
15 after rick brings home the
goat who he has bought with the bounties
on the three retr retired androids and
erin you know and rick talk back and
forth and you know they're very happy
and then she says
really we ought to go downstairs she
says let's run downstairs and give
thanks to mercer then we can come right
up here and name her she needs a name
maybe you can find some rope to tether
her
and why why is this important because
it would be immoral not to fuse with
mercer in gratitude she says i had a
hold of the handles of the box today and
it overcame my depression a little just
a little not like this and then she
shows him a bruise where she had gotten
hit by a rock and she says get in rick
this will just be for a minute you
hardly ever undergo fusion and then
here's where it comes in with another
interesting thing
it's not just a moral not to fuse with
mercer and gratitude
why is it immoral not to fuse with it
she talks she brings up the word immoral
again it would be immoral to keep their
joyful
mood to oneself as you're
a user using the empathy box fusing with
mercer you can transmit to others what
it is that you're feeling and you can
thereby
be supportive and in solidarity with
them
she says
i want you to transmit the mood you're
in now to everyone else you owe it to
them
it would be immoral to keep it for
ourselves
so they they go to go do that and she
goes on she says i want everyone to know
once that happened to me i fused and
picked up someone who had just acquired
an animal and then one day one day i
found myself receiving from someone
whose animal had died but others shared
our different joys with them i didn't
have any as you might know and that
cheered the person up we might even
reach a potential suicide what we have
what we're feeling might and now rick
says something interesting that shows
his perspective being very different
from from hers he's got kind of a
zero-sum
mentality
about this
he says they'll have our joy but will
lose we'll exchange what we feel for
what they feel our joy will be lost and
then aaron says
we won't really lose what we feel not if
we keep it clearly in mind you've never
really gotten the hang of fusion have
you rick so there's two different ways
of looking at it i i share in this and
if i'm bringing good stuff to it well
that's good for everybody else but it
kind of sucks for me because it's
literally sucking my joy out right and
aaron is saying no no you just hold on
to your joy and let it diffuse to other
people through their consciousness this
is another possibility
and it's you know two different
interesting models here now remember
that rick had talked about this earlier
empathy itself is
sharing the joy of others also sharing
the suffering of others right
so
they go on and
rick actually has
his first fateful encounter
with mercer he um here we go at the
black empathy box his wife crouched her
face wrapped he stood beside her for a
while his hand resting on her breast he
let it rise and fall the life in her in
the activity
erin did not notice him the experience
with mercer had has always become
complete on the screen the faint old
robed figure of mercer toiled upward a
rock sailed past him watching rick
thought my god there is something worse
about my situation than his
mercer doesn't have to do anything alien
to him
he suffers but at least he isn't
required to violate his own identity
and then he takes his wife's fingers off
the handles and takes her place
for the first time in weeks an impulse
that he hadn't planted at all
all at once had happened
and here we go a landscape of weeds
weeds confronted him at desolation the
air smelled of harsh blossoms this was a
desert there was no rain a man
stood before him a sowerful light in his
weary pain-drenched eyes
mercer rick said
i am your friend the old man said but
you must go on as if i did not exist can
you understand that
no rick said i can't understand that i
need help
how can i save you the old man said if i
can't save myself don't you see there is
no salvation
then what's this for rich man what are
you for
to show you wilbur mercer said
that you aren't alone i am here with you
and always will be
go and do your task even though you know
it is wrong why
rick said
why should i do it i'll quit my job and
emigrate the old man said and here's
where we get you know one of the key
passages of the book
you will be required to do wrong no
matter where you go it is the basic
condition of life to be required to
violate your own identity at some time
every creature which lives must do so it
is the ultimate shadow the defeat of
creation this is the curse at work the
curse that feeds on all life everywhere
in the universe
that's all you can tell me rick said
a rock was passed to me ducked and the
rock struck him on the ear at once he
let go of the handles and he stood in
his own living room beside his wife in
the empathy box
and
he tells her
i didn't get anything from holding on to
these handles mercer talked to me but it
didn't help he doesn't know any more
than i do he's just an old man climbing
a hill to his death
and she says isn't that the revelation
and he says well i have that revelation
already so it seems kind of inconclusive
right mercer has this experience to
offer people that you know irian and
isidore and other people like them get a
lot out of
deckard
he actually has this sort of privileged
encounter with mercer talking to him
one-on-one
and he's not getting from mercer what he
needs other than this assurance that
he's not unique in having to
as he says
do things that violate his own identity
so
we see that mercer plays an incredibly
important role within the narrative
world of this novel and for the
characters
who populate it
you